era da una vita da una vita che non
facevo un videogioco che meritasse così
tanto al gameplay
ragazzi miei siamo dentro bella tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video sono
fa vj e oggi vi faccio vedere che cosa
mi ha reso famoso su youtube risposta ai
giochi horror signori giochi horror ma
siamo nel 2017 i giochi horror si sono
evoluti avevamo amnesia avevamo slider
man una volta che cosa abbiamo in questo
2017 molto futuristico
ragazzi non so io partirei partirei
merci abel bello il cursore io partirei
perché con un intro così può
accompagnare su play è un videogioco
horror per quanto possa sembrare strano
colleziona 5 toilette e trova l'uscita
premi shift per correre bene io devo
collezionare il 5 tua lette e uscire
corri niente e il gioco this land airmen
fatto attuale è fantastico che mi sono
quelle che girano posso prendere questa
qua una banca 4 bene qua e vicolo cieco
lush.it vedo tutto offuscato con il
problema che pronto bagno madonna è
brutta almeno il bagno vorranno farlo
carino di qua non per una cosa ragazzi
hanno capito una cosa
l'unico problema è perché io devo
raccogliere le toilette qual è il mio
problema perché vedo tutto offuscato
consenso così di gli occhi si celi no
non è che perché gli occhi perché
ricorre nei cessi gli si appanna la
vista questa roba dello scontento sto
cesso
va bene ragazzi allora non ho mai capito
che dove dove dovrebbe essere nascosta
situa letto io corro il fatto ragazzi
che ancora nessuno mi sta seguendo sono
poi i vicoli ciechi col cazzo che
riprenda dalla leggera
secondo secondo cesso can't hide forma
assenti hamas e scherzando ma mi
chiamano 62 mila schon devo io quando
entrava il prof in classe si esce la
corsa dura veramente un secondo voi
tutti i fottuti successo no non puoi
nasconderti va bene ma io non ho capito
è una cosa infinita o se mi perdo un
cesso indietro devo tornare tutto
indietro perché se potrei perdermi
indietro un cesso sé ma tra i ragazzi
siamo a tre veloce quanto fottutamente
grosso sto bagno c'è una domanda
l'accesso un secondo si perde non torna
più a casa mai nella vita
445 blues
sì lei già detto questo siamo a quattro
su cinque ragazzi ne manca uno è ancora
non ho visto un mostro quindi perfetto
buongiorno essere il mostro del fermo
ciao zia devo passare quali grazie
attaccati al muro striscia zio striscia
beh bene non mi hanno non mi ha preso
con fantastico prossimi giro corre vero
il corri corri corri corri bene devo
capire un attimo dove trovare l'altro
cesso era qua lo penso
[ __ ] [ __ ] con riff rami che era
diventato difficile tutt'a un tratto sto
gioco plus vicolo cieco questa era gaby
croce con vicolo cieco
no non ci passo cazzo in serve che
faccia un po di passi avanti così io
passo di qua vai un due tre stella
con gli aveva però che cazzo
i ragazzi dall'inizio del video non
avevo ancora presa cioè non aveva ancora
vista come è possibile che ho postato un
video intero senza guardare dietro al
muro come che non ti sei fatta vedere
mezza volta ma devi rompere i [ __ ]
non ci passo e tria
forse sì forse sì ma non ci passo meno
ma meno male che è finito senza jobs che
robe del genere non aspettavo è stato
bruttissimo d'accordo ragazzi basta st
cagata più napoli è un'altra roba perché
sennò non ha senso vhs vi do horror
story
voi pensate lei che le cassette quelli
hs voglia dire video cazzo vuol dire vhs
che vuol dire video horror story non
avevano sempre detto sbagliato comunque
ragazzi sì ma io come ci sono finito qua
scusami ma cos'è però ancora fatto
niente cos'è ma sono io
io premo il tasto sinistro del mouse
non so per quale cambia frequenza per
rivelare gli oggetti ma dai ma che
storia ma che figata
veramente no ho capito la vera figata al
problema che non posso passare così in
realtà prima quale non c'era niente solo
che mi sono voluto complicare la vita
cos'è sta roba
c'è una traccia di sangue rivela gli
altri oggetti ok
salve a una cravatta lei simpatica come
molto simpatica permesso sono fa vj sono
uno che fa le frequenze fatto si guarda
molto simpatico
non riesco a passare oltre fammi passare
a ha quindi proprio ci sono delle cose
che io non vedo che comunque ci sono
sarebbe solo di trasportare trasportarmi
poche parole invece no ok ok ok non mi
far cambiano non voglio che avrebbe
cambiato la guarda che pensavo molto
peggio è veramente molto peggio cos'è
questa merda usiamo vedo contro chi vado
a sbattere vado alla quanto si brutto ma
cos'è sembra sembra un pokémon e kabul
tops uguale ancora
picchia che ansia vorrei corridoi e
vivaci aperte diamo di qualche arrivato
di quanto inquina meno sicuro di qua non
può arrivare te l'ho detto io di qua
infatti non c'è un cazzo se per caso per
qualcuno tipo torna indietro sono morto
bruttissimo basta basta basta per oggi
va bene così tra accesso e questo
riguarda champagne bella brava e carina
l'idea di bruciare fare ai ragazzi spero
che questo video vi sia piaciuto i temi
con levette preferito tra questo e
quello del cesso io ho quello per un
primo momento mi sono sentito un
fenomeno
poi io ho fatto cagare però all'inizio
sotto bravo soli quindi ragazzi spero
che questo video ti è piaciuto come sede
di un momento e mi piace anche vari
social che come invito a stare
iscrizione servizi idrici che diavolo
fossimo vinto dai ragazzi